I'll say this to the last thing on Jake
Paul you know Jake Paul offered Nate
Diaz uh MMA fight where this gets tricky
again and Nate would be a huge favor in
that and he should be if that were to
happen to pfl and Nate goes to pfl
direction for the money that 10 million
or whatever they're offering him if he
does do that you're never getting the
trilogy fight with Connor Dana's not
gonna allow it because he hit him
fighting for another organization Dana's
never let him come back no I know about
Dana that if he does decide to do that
then you're forfeiting the Conor
McGregor fight in the UFC then Jake has
a deal with pfl I don't think it's gonna
allow him to fight in the UFC
so I think if Nate they got to figure it
out what's best much easier fight
against Jake and MMA right 10 million
well how much would you make fighting
Conor McGregor in the UFC legit fight
big fight Main Event the media behind it
the PowerHouse machine of the UFC like
what do you want to do here